hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm and today started one of
the biggest tournaments of the year it's
the Sinquefield Cup the fourth annual
held in st. Louis Missouri with ten of
the top players in the world it is the
third tournament in the leg of the 2016
grand chest tour so very very
prestigious tournament now the leader of
the grand chest or Magnus Carlsen is not
participating he's getting ready for the
World Championships later in November
well we still have ten of the top
players in the Grand chest tour today's
match we're gonna actually be seeing
number two verse number three they're
tied so this tournament means a lot to
them and it's actually two Americans so
playing on US soil in st. Louis Missouri
we have Wesley so gonna be playing the
white pieces in round one his opponent
playing the black pieces is going to be
Nakamura so starts out with pawn to d4
Knight f6 pawn C for Pawnee six Knight
f3 and after pawn to d5 we're getting
into the Catalan opening with pawn to g3
it's an open thing we don't see all too
often but is always interesting to see
at the highest level it's a kind of a
combo between the Queens gambit and also
the ready opening Black has two options
he could not take this material and c4
that would be the closed variation or
you can always take this material for
the open line and then try to either
hold on to that material or just give
that material back and then try to
progress and attack on the Queen side of
the board will continue Bishop e7 Bishop
d2 castle on the Kings side and then
Nakamura decides to go ahead and take
here on c4 from here why it's gonna
continue with Knight to e5 this is a few
things one it immediately strikes back
to go ahead and get this material back
on c4 it also opens up the door for this
LightSquared Bishop to really control
this long diagonal sometimes black would
try to hold on to that material with
pawn to b5 but you can see right away
that's not going to work
since the bishop is controlling can just
go ahead and take that rook here on a8
so instead continues with Knight to c6
opting to go ahead and give back this
material
if so once to go ahead and take this so
decides not to he decided to go and take
with his night here and then after the
pond recaptures night here to a three
very interesting I think it would have
been slightly easier I want all the
betters the right term but a little bit
easier just to take with the bishop here
the pawn could recapture and then after
the night takes here we could see the
Queen to d7 and that appear east seven
Queen takes Queen up here a five I think
this looks really good can get this
material back if he wants to has a nice
structure with this pawn she's gonna
have an isolated pawn here on the C file
for Nakamura so all in all I think this
is a really good play for four so he
decided and said to go to take with his
night after the pawn takes Knight here
to a3 and this is this is a pretty
questionable move if you ask me I think
it makes a lot of sense just to take
with the bishop on c6 he decides one to
go ahead and leave his opponent with a
triple pawns here on the C file they are
all isolated which I do like that
because you can attack this later on but
Knight to a3 is just kind of weird he
could easily get this involved into the
center of the game really really use
that to control but instead he decides
to go and give himself double pawns here
on the a foul so just really did not
want his opponent to have a dark squared
bishop instead giving himself double
pawns on a two and a three seems a
little bit odd to me but that's what's
so decided he wanted to go ahead and
play a bishop here a six Queen d2 rook
here b8 controlling this long open file
Queen up here to a5 so starting to put a
little pressure there's a lot going on
on the Queen side of the board King side
both sides are pretty safe here even
insert of the board with some of those
nights off the board there's not much
going on so there's gonna be a lot of
action going on on this side of the
board for a while knock more continues
with Queen to c8 protecting the bishop
here on a six and then pawn up here a
for allowing for the bishop later on to
come here to a3 a rook to d8 attacking
the square here on d4 and then Bishop to
eighth
now after the route comes down that
looks a little surprising so has given
Nakamura a two pond lead in the game but
he doesn't necessarily have that big of
an advantage yes
he is up to pawns but if we look at it
from Nakamura side he has three ponds on
the c-file they are all isolated there
are no ponds on the beat or the D files
to kind of protect them so that's gonna
be hard for him to hold on to but so on
the other hand he can always play Bishop
to c5 attacking the rook also attacking
the pawn here on a7 if there is any
other sort of shenanigans the bishop can
always come here to c6 take that
material so so although he is down
material now he does have some strong
attacks a little bit later on on the
Queen side that he can employ so we see
rook to be one could also played rook to
be one as well from a1 it does have some
options but decides to go and play rook
here to be one I look down here b6
could've been interesting just take down
here get some material off the board
anytime you're up in material if you can
just exchange down to almost nothing
just your pawns you could have a very
strong endgame but plays rook here b6
and then Bishop to c5 attacking both the
rooks here on a b6 and a d4 nakamora
decides he wants to go and hang on to
his D file rook and so we see rook to
the one h6 I'm not sure you should have
played h6 I think that's really just
getting away from kind of the action
here on the Queen side his opponent
decided not to take the rook right away
so if he's gonna do that I say go ahead
and bring the rook down here - B - now
you're not gonna lose a rook all of a
sudden you're on your opponent's second
rank which is where you really want to
be with your rooks if you're black if
you're white you want to be having your
rooks on the seventh ring this is just
applying a lot of pressure pawn here on
e - is under pressure the rook can't
come away from a one also you can start
to add more pressure with this pawn
pushing forward since he has some
protection here with his rook
later down on this second rank but he
decided to go ahead and play a pawn to
a6 and then there is an exchange on
board
rook takes here on d7 we see the knight
take and then the bishop takes here on
b6 after the pawn recaptures then the
Queen swings back here to d2 so if we
can't look at we have six pawns for
white we have a lot more was eight pawns
for black above Ducey in exchange
instead of a bishop and a knight we do
see the bishop and the rook for white so
getting into the endgame if we can get
these Queens off the board a bishop and
rook in game is gonna be much more
dangerous than a bishop in a night in
game just because the the rook is so
powerful it can control so much of the
board
I really just put a lot of pressure get
behind enemy lines and start to gobble
up the pawns so that's what both sides
are gonna be looking to do not come or
really wants to just hold on to his at
pawn advantage really start to push in
the center of the board maybe he can
forces enemy to make a mistake he can
promote what these pawns and he can end
up winning the game with that strategy
but right now he is somewhat in a tough
spot knowing that so has the better
endgame we see pawn to c5 here from
knocking more solidifying his pawn chain
if you kind of analyze this a little bit
further if you kind of watch some of the
the commentary from the the match today
live they really like the move Knight to
c5 yes it doesn't solidify the pawn
chain but this pawn right here on c6 it
is being protected by the Queen on c8 so
it does already have that protection but
then I don't see five is just doing a
lot more on board than the pawn to c5
which isn't doing too much on board but
in the game we see pawn to c5 and then
rook over here to d1 controlling this D
file putting a lot of pressure on the
night here on d7 the knight comes over
here to f6 getting out of harm's way and
then King over here to f1 realizing this
is kind of getting into the endgame
knowing that if the Queen and rook start
to push up the board the King has to be
aware that this pawn can start
down here to see once that's why you see
that move here to f1 it's thinking many
many moves ahead thinking about all the
options of how Nakamura could actually
win this game Nakamura plays King to h7
just making sure that if there's a Queen
to d8 there's an exchange on board
there's not a tempo gained so decides to
go and play King to h7 first we see
Queen to see to check King back here to
g8 king d2 King age 7 so that this is a
two-fold repetition so has the option
right here to go and have a threefold
repetition have a draw for the first
game but he actually really likes his
position so he wants to go ahead and
continue play it out so he changes it up
a little bit does not want to draw with
the threefold repetition if you're not
familiar with the threefold repetition
if you have the same setup on the board
and you move just back and forth for
three moves it will be a drawn game so
after Queen to d8 we do see the Queen
take rook takes here on d8 and then pawn
to c3 so if you have a passed pawn you
need to push that pass pawn as fast as
possible so Nakamura knows his his road
to victory is gonna be this pawn pushing
forward this rook here on da it's gonna
be causing a lot of problems get behind
enemy lines you can start to gobble up
pawns all these pawns are ready to be
taken also pretty much has to do is stop
the push from Nakamura starts out with
King to e1 that's why that move form f1
was so important because he could not
get back there fast enough with some of
his other material Bishop here to c4
just centralizing King to d1 Bishop
takes here on a 2 doesn't matter too
much though so although he's giving up
material he can get that material back
if he wants to he just needs to make
sure he stops this push with the pawn
here from c3 King up here to see 2
getting ready to gobble that up Bishop
to c4 pawn to e3 recognized and he could
take this pawn if he wanted to but he
does not want to give up any more pawns
that he has to and you'll see this a lot
any time your opponent has a specific
bish
on boards in this particular case we see
a light to my bishop you'll start to put
all your pawns on the other square so
these are the dark squares and now so
doesn't have to worry about any these
ponds being a target for this light
square bishop pawn here to be 5 this is
protecting the bishop and also attacking
the pawn right here King up here to c3
this also does keep the pawn on b5 at
bay it can't take the pawn here on a4
because just the bishops going to fall
right away so can't do that pawn here to
a6 just adding a little bit of
protection on the pawn here on b5 rook
over here 8/8 attacking the pawn as we
talked about Knights to the 5 forcing
the King to move also allowing the pawn
to come down here on b4 a little bit
later but we first see in exchange on
board the bishop takes here on d5 the
bishop wasn't doing too much and just
getting down to an in game with a rook
first bishops gonna be even better for
so so you see the pawn take here on d5
upon to a5 now all the pawns are on dark
squares that's exactly what so wants to
be doing here paneer to be for King
comes back here d2 Bishop back f1 rook
to see AIT's just adding pressure on
this pawn the pawns gonna come down here
c4 look over here b8 kind of forcing the
moves after pawn to b3 we see King to c3
and from this position Nakamura actually
resigned so so ended up winning Game one
there's no great way for knocking more
to continue in the endgame the richer's
going to dominate all these pawns can
play rook to b7 looking to gobble up the
pawn here on f7 can come over here to a
eights goblet material look here to d8
all those are fun eventually this pawns
going to fall there's a passed pawn
there's no way that this King can really
control it at the end of the day it's
gonna be a long game I'll be completely
honest with you but at the end of day
knocker more realizes he just can't win
this and so has the dominant in game so
although Nakamura ended up resigning so
wins game
one huge victory for him I really
thought kind of the top two players
especially for the Grand Tour coming in
they wouldn't really do anything too
crazy we'd play a pretty draw game but
at the end of the day so came out played
a very interesting variation of the
Catalan opening and at the end of day he
gets the victory so congratulations to
him winning Game one Nakamura is gonna
be looking to battle back not the start
that he was looking for at the same
field Cup but a lot of rounds left to go
so hopefully you guys are excited about
this tournament we're gonna be doing
videos every night that there is around
for the next week and a half so expect a
lot of videos from this tournament thank
you guys so much for watching I'll see
you in round 2